ONLY FOR MEMBERS THIS IS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN MARCH TWENTY
SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AT
ONE ONE THIRTY FIVE THE
SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WELCOME TO OUR FIRST LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HEARING IN JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING RULES TO REMIND YOU.
OF WHAT WE DO IN THIS -- THIS
ROOM.
UP FIRST I WONDER WELCOME BACK
ARE RETURNING MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US ASSEMBLYMEMBER WILL
PALE IN OUR VICE CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR DEDICATION THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND A WARM WELCOME TO OUR NEW
NUMBER MEMBERS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OWNER HARDCORE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RITA ROBERT
RIVAS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US -- SPEAKER RENDON HAS
APPOINTED ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TASHA ****
HARVARD FOR TODAY'S HEARING ONLY.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS
BILLS AND SIGN IN ORDER WE HAVE
SIX ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY --
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE LACKEY.
LACKEY HERE BLOOM.
BLOOM HERE CHIU.
RAMOS.
RAMOS HERE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUR FIRST
BILL THIS WITH THIS AFTERNOON IS
A ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
SIX EIGHTEEN WELCOME US WELCOME
TO OUR VERY FIRST ME ARE VERY
FIRST PERSON TO RE HERE'S
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
THIS WILL BE
.
AND IS ONE OF THE LOW WELL
CITIES IT REALLY STRUGGLES.
EVEN THOUGH IT HAS A FAIRLY
DECENT PROPERTY TAX BASE GIVEN
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE THEY GET
VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THAT.
THAT THE CITY HAS LONG BEEN VERY.
VERY FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE AND
HOW IT MANAGES ITS FINANCES AND
IN FACT IS GOING TO GO THROUGH A
BUDGETING PROCESS COMING UP.
AND HAS ASKED ME TO BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN THEY
CAN LOOK AT THIS.
SALES TAX AS A POTENTIAL TOOL AS
THEY FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE MANAGING THEIR
BUDGET PROVIDING THE SERVICES
THAT ARE EXPECTED BY THEIR
CONSTITUENCIES.
THIS IS IN THE SAME FORM AS
OTHER BILLS SIMILAR THEY'RE
ABOUT TO THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES AND I HAVE WITH ME JIM
READ.
WHO IS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AS
SEVERAL TIME MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF SCOTTS VALLEY LONG STANDING?
LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBER AND
MEMBER OF THE CITY COUNCIL AND
WHO HAS BEEN A VERY SIGNIFICANT
PART OF MANAGING THE CITY AND
BROUGHT THIS BILL TO MY
ATTENTION THE NEED FOR THIS BILL
TO MY ATTENTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I QUITE.
SO IT MARK PUT IT VERY WELL WE
ARE LOW WELL CITY -- WE ONLY GET
BACK ABOUT SIX AND A HALF
PERCENT OF OUR PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE.
AND WE'VE HAD SEVERAL TIMES IN
THE PAST WHERE BECAUSE WE YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE AUTO
DEALERSHIPS IN OUR TIME WE DON'T
HAVE A LARGE MALL WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF TRADITIONALLY LARGE
SALES TAX GENERATORS.
SO WHEN TIMES ARE REALLY GOOD WE
DON'T SEE A SPIKE THE LOT OF
JURISDICTIONS TO WERE JUST FLAT.
AND SO EVEN IN THE CON TO BE
LIKE THIS DESPITE US BEING VERY
VERY FRUGAL -- ANYTIME AN
EMPLOYEE LEAVES FIGHT NATURAL
ATTRITION WE TRY NOT TO REPLACE
THEM -- WE'VE GOT ABOUT I THINK
ABOUT 2025% LIGHTER -- AND
STAFFING THAT WE WERE JUST
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO MAKE ENDS MEET -- THIS BEEN A
PERENNIAL PROBLEM FOR US IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE OUR ANSWER WAS TO
DO A TEMPORARY FIVE YEAR QUARTER
CENT SALES TAX WE WENT OUT TO
THE VOTERS WITH.
WE GOT 72% ON THAT WE LET IT
EXPIRE WE HOPE WE ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH SOME
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INITIATIVES
THAT WOULD ENABLE US TO RIGHT
THE SHIP FISCALLY.
THOSE DIDN'T COME TO PASS
LARGELY BECAUSE THE ECONOMY SO
INTO TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN EXCUSE ME WE WENT OUT
FOR A SEVEN YEAR HALF CENT.
SALES TAX.
AND AGAIN WE ENGAGED COMMUNITY
ENOUGH HONEST CONVERSATION HERE
THE SERVICES THAT WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE YOU TODAY.
WE DON'T SEE ANY OF ANY PLACE
MORE THAN WE CAN CUT WE'VE LAID
OFF PEOPLE WHEN TIMES ARE BAD
WE'VE CUT THIS CORNER THAT
CORNER BUT WE DON'T THINK WE CAN
CUT ANYMORE WITHOUT CUTTING BONE
AND MUSCLE.
AND WE'VE INVITED THE COMMUNITY
COME LOOK AT OUR BOOKS TELL US A
FOR MISSING SOMETHING AND WE HAD
VERY STRONG SWEET COMMITTEE
SUPPORT. FOR THAT MEASURE WE GOT
76% OF THE VOTE NOW IS THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SAID WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LOOK AT ANOTHER OPTION I
THINK POTENTIALLY GOING UP TO
THREE QUARTERS OF A CENT.
IT'S NOT DEFINITE YET -- WILL
KNOW THAT AT THE END OF OUR
BUDGET PROCESS -- IN MAY OR JUNE
BUT PERSONALLY I THINK IT'S BEEN
FAR MORE LIKELY THAN NOT THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED THAT THREE
QUARTERS SENT. TO OUR COMMUNITY
CAN CONTINUE TO ENJOY THE
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE TODAY --
SO IF WE JUST HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ENGAGE IN THAT HONEST
CONVERSATION WITH OUR ELECTORATE
ABOUT THE PLUSES AND MINUSES OF
THIS ADDITIONAL REVENUE AND WHAT
IT'LL GO -- FOR WE THINK THE IT
WOULD BE A GREAT SERVICE -- TO
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRING THIS UP IN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME THANK YOU --
FOR TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND WE
SEE OUR LOCALS COME AND TESTIFY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
THING OTHER THAN THE OPPOSITION
.
WHAT KIND OF COURSE?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION TO YOU AB SIX ONE
EIGHT AND MEMBERS WE'VE -- SALES
TAX AUTHORIZATION BILLS LIKE
THIS -- ONE FOR AS LONG AS THE
TWELVE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN AT
HOWARD JARVIS ANYTHING EVEN NOW
LISTEN THIS DOES A BY BY LOCAL
VOTER APPROVAL AND OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE VERY.
PLEASED BY THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
BECAUSE WE'RE DEALING WITH
PROGRESSIVE SALES TAX --
AUTHORIZATIONS HERE SCOTTS
VALLEY HAS A 9% SALES TAX RATE --
ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN THE STATE
CERTAINLY IN THE TOP 20% OF ALL
OF THE JURISDICTIONS THAT
ACTUALLY AUTHOR IS SALES TAXES
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT CONSUMER SPENDING MAKES UP --
ABOUT 70% OF THE NATION'S
ECONOMIC OUTPUT AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT VERY REGRESSIVE
TAX INCREASES HERE --
AUTHORIZATIONS OF THIS KIND ARE
VERY CONCERNING TO US AND YOU
KNOW WE UNDERSTAND COMMUNITIES
NEED MORE MONEY -- AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE SYMPATHETIC TO THAT
OBVIOUSLY UP TO A POINT BUT WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER A LOT OF THIS
MONEY IS GOING TO GO TO UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITIES ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
GENERAL TAX WHICH WE ARE HERE.
THERE'S NO REASON THAT THIS
FUNDS CAN'T BE SPENT FOR
ANYTHING INCLUDING UNFUNDED
PENSION LIABILITIES.
AND WE JUST THINK DEALING WITH
PROGRESSIVE TAXES OF THIS TYPE
FOR THAT PURPOSES UNWISE SO FOR
THOSE REASONS ASPIRIN OF A THANK
YOU VERY MUCH EITHER IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU LIKE TO COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
PARKING IS HORRENDOUS I JUST GO
HERE.
YEAH THE NO IT SHOULD BE ON
RIGHT.
AND THEN AS WE LOOK IT UP JUST
LIKE THAT.
I'M IN A POSITION I I ASSUME
WE'RE STILL IN A CA ONE NO.
THOUGH THIS IS.
ANOTHER BILL I SAW MR WEALTH
HERE AND FIGURED THIS WAS THE
ONE AND PARKING IS THE PITS OUT
THERE THANK YOU.
HE'LL BE HERE FOR AWHILE TODAY.
OKAY IS THE WHAT.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION FOR ABC SIX
EIGHTEEN THING NONE.
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
I HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND IT.
HEY WE HAVE A MORE SECOND ANY
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD.
BUT OF SHARON AND JUST BRIEFLY I
FIND THE OPPOSITION A LITTLE BIT
DISINGENUOUS.
YES SALES TAXES ARE REGRESSIVE
ABSOLUTELY AND IF WE'RE GONNA
HAVE AN HONEST CONVERSATION
ABOUT SALES TAX IN THE AFFECTED
SALES TAXES.
THE REASON THE RATE IS SO HIGH
IS THE SALES AND USE TAX WAS PUT
IN PLACE WHEN WE WERE PROBABLY
70% GOODS ECONOMY.
NOW SIT CALIFORNIA'S PROBABLY
70% SERVICES ECONOMY.
SO THOUGH THE RATE GOES UP
BECAUSE THE BASE HAS GONE DOWN
AND IF BY THEIR CONCERN FOR A
REGRESSIVE TAX THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION SAYING WE
SHOULD LOOK AT MAKING.
SALES AND USE TAX LESS
REGRESSIVE BY TAXING ACROSS THE
ECONOMY I WOULD WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE AND I'M HOPING THAT
THEY'LL BE A PARTNER TO HELP US
ADDRESS THE REQUESTED MISS OF
THAT.
OTHER THAN THAT WE HAVE REMOVED
FROM LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MANY OF
THE LEVERS THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO FUNCTION AND TO OPERATE
WE EVER SEVERELY RESTRICTED.
THEIR ABILITY TO RAISE AND TAKE
BENEFIT OF THEIR LOCAL PROPERTY
TAXES IS ONE PROP THIRTEEN WAS
PUT INTO PLACE CITIES LIKE
SCOTTS VALLEY WHICH ARE VERY
SMALL IN IN A RURAL AREA.
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE GROWTH OF THE
VALUE OF THEIR PROPERTIES OVER
THE YEARS BECAUSE OF THESE RULES
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE AND
REALLY STRANGLED CITIES.
SO THAT THIS IS A CITY THAT HAS
BEEN FISCALLY VERY RESPONSIBLE
OF A CITY THAT HAS ALWAYS GONE
OUT TO THE VOTERS IN A
TRANSPARENT WAY.
ALL WE'RE ASKING HERE TODAY IS
THAT WE ALLOW THE VOTERS
THEMSELVES TO ASK THE QUESTION
OF THEMSELVES THAN HOLD THEIR
CIVIC LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE. TO
THE TO THE DECISION OF WHETHER
OR NOT THEY WANT.
TO RAISE THE SALES TAX NOW THEY
WOULD I'M SURE LOVE TO NOT HAVE
TO USE THIS PARTICULAR LEVER.
BUT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OTHERS
WE'VE HAD BETWEEN THE CITY IN
THE COUNTY.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME DISPUTES
BACK AND FORTH BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
TRYING TO PROTECT ITSELF AND ITS
ABILITY TO TAKE ITS FAIR SHARE.
OF THAT PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
BUT UNDER THE EXISTING STRUCTURE
THAT HAS PROVEN IMPOSSIBLE TO DO.
SO WE HAVE TO PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF SOMEWHERE.
THIS IS THE ONLY LEVER THAT THEY
HAVE I ASKED FOR IT I VOTE TO
GIVE SCOTTS VALLEY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRY AND HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION.
IN A STRAIGHTFORWARD MANNER WITH
THEIR CONSTITUENCIES AND BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS THEIR PHYSICAL NEEDS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I ASKED
FOR AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY I SUPPORT THE EFFORTS OF
THE COMMUNITY.
IN SOLVING A FUNDING CHALLENGES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING
THAT FORWARD WITH THAT -- WILL
TAKE THE ROLE FOR THE BUT WHAT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY NO LACKEY NO BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHIU [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAMOS NOT VOTING THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL.
THANK YOU VENTURE.
THE ITS AUTO MOUNT NEED THREE
VOTES THANK YOU.
LIKE AND POSTED ON THE HE WAS.
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTEEN ALL RIGHT --
IT'S YOUR LUCKY DAY MISTER
COOLING -- IF WE WOULD LOVE FOR
YOU TO PRESENT YOUR BILL THIS IS
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS HIS MAIN
NUMBER FOR MY CORRECT AB. EIGHT
EIGHTEEN IS THAT CORRECT.
YES ALL RIGHT.
READY TO GO GOOD AFTERNOON
COLLEAGUES GOOD AFTERNOON -- I
AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB --
EIGHT ONE EIGHT THIS BILL
FOCUSES ON SUPPORTING LOCAL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONE IMPROVE
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE AND FORMER
CITY.
AND THE MIND SINESTRO GROWS OUT
OF MY OWN CITY.
WHICH INCORPORATED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE JUST BEFORE THE
RULES CHANGE.
AND THE EXISTENCE OF THE VEHICLE
LICENSE FEE FEE FUNDING STREAM A
STRUCTURE THAT TIME.
BECAME VERY INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
VIABILITY OF MY NEW CITY AND
THEY BELIEVE US TO GO FROM
GROUND ZERO TO ESTABLISH
OURSELVES AS A COMMUNITY.
WHICH IS TO SAY.
YES CITY HOOD MOVEMENT IS ALL
ABOUT BRINGING YOUR FUTURE HOME.
WHEN THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DOWNTOWN FOR ON A
CORPORATE JERRY LITERALLY?
AS WELL AS FIGURATIVELY BRINGING
THAT YOUR FUTURE INTO THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE LOCALS. FOR
MOST OF OUR THE COMMUNITY SEE
THEIR NAMES ARE DAY CAN MAKE
DECISIONS.
ABOUT THE FUTURE -- IN TWENTY
ELEVEN OF THE LEGISLATURE PASSES
CREATED IT HELP CLOSE HUGE
BUDGET GAP.
THAT BILL REMOVED ALLOCATIONS OF
THE PLO FROM CITIES AFFECTED
RATE IN POSSIBLE. TO FORM A NEW
CITY.
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THAT BARRIER --
THE ROSE TO THAT MEASURE THERE'S
BEEN NO INCORPORATION SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN TO AB EIGHT ONE
EIGHT SEEKS TO RESTORE THIS
CRITICAL FUNDING MECHANISM TO
SUPPORT LOCAL SELF DETERMINATION.
AND ENHANCE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
BY THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
COMMUNITIES WHO SEEK SOMETHING
DIFFERENT FOR THE FUTURE.
AW I AM JOINED AS A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL WITH DOCTOR QUIRK
WHO'S BEEN A VERY STOUT ADVOCATE
OF THIS WITH ME -- IN RECENT
YEARS AND DâN CARED FOR THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES SO LET ME TURN
TO MISTER KERIK.
AND WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES WITH
US.
WILL WEIGH IN THE FLICK.
YES BEFORE YOU START OKAY I WANT
REMIND YOU GET TWO PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I FORGOT THANK YOU
MISSION.
A MAN CHAIRED MEMBERS -- DICK
YOU'RE GONNA BE AWFULLY
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN WORKING FOR THE WEEK
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS BUT WHEN I
STARTED RANCHO CORDOVA WAS
ACTUALLY IN THE PROCESS OF THE
RESIDENTS RUSHED OR GOING
THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF TRYING
TO INCORPORATE SO.
IT'S BEEN SOMETHING THAT I'VE
I'VE SEEN ALL THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER -- THE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
IT DURING THE RECESSION -- THERE
WAS A A TRAILER BILL THAT WENT
THROUGH WITHOUT REALLY A LOT OF
REVIEW IT ONE OF THE THINGS IT
IT THE THAT IT DID WAS IT TOOK
AWAY -- THAT REALLY THE THE THE
FOUNDATIONAL OF FINANCING ARM ON
THE THAT IS WAS AVAILABLE TO IN
CORPORATIONS PRIOR TO THAT DATE --
TWO YEARS AGO AS PART OF A
LEGISLATIVE DECISION THERE WAS A
A FIX THERE WERE FOUR RECENTLY
INCORPORATED CITIES THAT WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY HARMED BY THAT BY
THAT TRAILER BILL THERE WAS A
FIX IT ALL THE LEGISLATORS AGREE.
TO ALL THIS BILL DOES IS GIVE
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY FOR FUTURE
COMMUNITIES TO TO USE THE SAME
METHOD -- THAT WAS APPROVED FOR
THE FOR CITIES -- IN ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO BY THE UNANIMOUSLY BY
THE LEGISLATURE BUT THIS ISN'T A
ON A SILVER BULLET.
EVEN IF THIS ALL OF THIS BILL IS
PASSED IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT SOME
OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
REPRESENTED YEAR OLD WHO
ACTUALLY ACHIEVING CORPORATION
THERE'S LOTS OF OTHER HOOPS AND
HURDLES THEY'VE GOT TO GO
THROUGH.
BUT IT LEAST GETS THEM BACK TO A
LEAST AT THE STARTING POINT THAT
THEY HAD -- PRIOR TO THE TRAILER
BILL AND AND SO FOR THOSE
REASONS -- IT AND FOR ALL THE
COMMUNITIES -- THAT ARE HERE ON
THE TABLE THERE REALLY ALL
LOOKING FOR SELF GOVERNMENT FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE SERVED ON
CITY COUNCILS AND BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS YOU UNDERSTAND THE
THE VALUE OF THAT AND AND THERE
ARE.
YOU KNOW LOOK AT LOOKING TO AT
LEAST HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
HAVE THE SAME -- SAME
OPPORTUNITY -- TO TO TO GATHER
COMMUNITIES HAVE MORE SELF
GOVERNMENT -- THAT THAT YEAH YOU
DID AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR THOSE
REASONS WE SUPPORT -- LET ME ASK
FOR THE LADIES TO SPEAK AS THE
MEN OF HAD THE SHOW SO FAR.
THANK YOU FOR BEING SO OBSERVER
MISTER.
I'M NOT A KNUCKLE HEAD.
ALL THE TIME.
OKAY GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TIME TODAY MY
NAME IS SERRA RAYMOND'S I'M A
RESIDENT OF ONE OF THESE ARE
MANY UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES.
I'M NOT SURE THAT MATTERS WHICH
WON THE SUFFICE IT TO SAY MIND
COMPRISES OVER SIXTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE -- THERE ARE OVER SIX
MILLION PEOPLE LIKE ME IN
CALIFORNIA LIVING IN
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF ELECTED
REPRESENTATION DIRECT TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES -- LIVING WITHOUT
THAT SORT OF ON COURT.
WITHOUT A CORPORATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IT'S UNDEMOCRATIC
ITS DIFFERENCES IT DOESN'T
FRANCHISING IT MEANS WE DON'T
HAVE LOCAL ELECTED GOVERNMENT
FROM MILLIONS OF US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I'M.
IT MEANS THAT RED TAPE -- IS
HIGHER FOR US IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND FEWER LOCAL IDEAS COME TO
FRUITION IN OUR COMMUNITY IF.
IT TAKES RESOURCES FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES AND RESIDENTS TO
COUNTIES PRIORITIES WHICH OFTEN
DON'T MATCH WITH OUR DIRECT
PRIORITIES IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT THIS
HAS GOT TO CHANGE -- MILLIONS OF
US ARE LIVING WITH THESE SYSTEMS
BECAUSE THE FUNDING STREAM --
THAT PREVIOUSLY SUPPORTED IN
CORPORATIONS TAKING AWAY FROM
OFF AND THIS BILL PROVIDES A
MUCH NEEDED LEGISLATIVE FIX WITH
OUR WHAT WE SEE OF MINIMAL IF IN.
A MINIMAL FISCAL IMPACT ON THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TIME.
IF I MAY JUMP IN JUST FOR A
MOMENT AND WHEN I AM GOING TO
ASK EACH PERSON IDENTIFY
YOURSELF -- I OF COURSE
RECOGNIZES YOU ALL DO IN MY
COLLEAGUES FROM -- SAM BIRD IN A
COUNTY BOARD SUPERVISORS THERE
IS LOCAL GOVERNMENT A FORM OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR
THESE COMMUNITIES.
BUT I'VE YOU THAT IS THE WAY
I'VE UNIT GOING DOOR TO DOOR IN
RANCHO CORDOVA I HAVE A TERRIFIC
COUNTY SUPERVISOR. FOR RANGE
GROW DONNA TOLLEY.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY TO PEOPLE
ARRANGEMENT -- WHEN I'D GO DOOR
TO DOOR IN TWO THOUSAND TWO IS
WELL YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS?
ONLY ONE REPRESENTS OUR
COMMUNITY DONDE TOLD A GREAT GUY
BUT HE ACTUALLY HAS THE BIGGEST
DISTRICT IN THE COUNTY.
SO ON ANY GIVEN DAY WE ONLY HAVE
A PIECE OF DONNA TOLL IS FOCUS.
BECAUSE IT JUST WAS SO LARGE.
ANY OTHER AS TO THE OTHER FOR
THEIR ONLY THINKING ABOUT
RICHARD OVER IN A IN A SORT OF
PER FOR A WAY. TO THEIR
DISTRICTS.
SO IT'S NOT THAT THERE IS NOT
THAT REPRESENTATION BUT CITY
HOOD AFFORDS A CONCENTRATED
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE. FIVE PEOPLE
ALL THE TIME IF THAT'S THE
NUMBER YOU HAVE -- AND IT'S SO
IT IS A DIFFERENCE IN QUALITY.
WHICH IS WHY TO ME CITY WHO IS
ALL ABOUT BRINGING YOUR FUTURE
HOME RIGHT THERE IN THE BORDERS.
SO I DO WANT TO SAM BEHALF OF
THOSE MEMBERS ABOARD SUPERVISORS
HERE WE DO KNOW DO DELIVER LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT IT IS OF A DIFFERENT QUALITY
AND IT'S A PART OF A LARGER.
SPAN OF RESPONSIBILITY BEN AND
JERRY.
RETURN IT TO YOU.
DO YOU HAVE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AND JUST BY YOUR NAME IN IF YOU
SUPPORT IT.
AND A FOR PURE POSITION THAT'S
FINE.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL COULD CHECK I
AM FROM ON A CORPORATE CASSEROLE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'VE BEEN TRACKING THIS SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN WHEN I LEARNED
SOMETHING ABOUT CALL VEHICLE
LICENSE FEE FOR THE FIRST TIME.
AND HAVE STUDENTS SOLIDARITY
WITH THOSE FOUR CITIES IN
RIVERSIDE IN THERE AND
CORPORATION EFFORTS I JUST WANT
TO SAY OUR COALITION HERE IS
NONPARTISAN WE REPRESENT
REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS
LIBERTARIANS GREENS.
AND IT REALLY SHOULD BE
SOMETHING ABOUT -- GIVING US THE
POWER AS PEOPLE TO FIGHT FOR THE
CHANCE FROM CORPORATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOUR NAME IN YOUR
POSITION -- POSES A IS A
SUPPORTER OPPOSE REGISTER NAME
IN YOUR MY NAME IS KATHERINE
GORGEOUS I AM FROM THE LARGEST
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITY AND
STANISLAUS COUNTY IS A LEADER.
AND I TOTALLY SUPPORTS THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS PARECIA SPRIGS I'M
FROM UNINCORPORATED ASHLAND
WHERE AN EXTRA NEIGHBORS TO
CAPTURE VALLEY IN A CLUSTER OF
UNINCORPORATED AREAS.
ACTUALLY WE IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WE
HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND UNINCORPORATED
RESIDENTS AND ON OUR OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD IS FOR PRIMARILY
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MY AND
IMMIGRANTS SO WE HAVE DEFINITELY
BEEN IGNORED WE'RE WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT MARK NORD -- BECAUSE
OF THAT FACT AND IT'S DEFINITELY
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AND WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR A FIX FOR A
LONG TIME I DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THEM.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BRING OUR
DEMOCRACY TO ALL SIX MILLION ON
IT CALIFORNIA UNINCORPORATED
RESIDENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
YES SIR.
YOU'RE MICHAEL SEMEN I RESIDE IN
ARDEN ARCADE AND SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WE HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE THERE -- IN
UNINCORPORATED AREA -- I HAVE A
LETTER FROM CALIFORNIA
UNINCORPORATED WHICH IS OUR
COALITION OF ELEVEN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS EIGHT
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA I'LL JUST
LEAVE IT HERE WITHOUT READING IT
WOULD LIKE TO THE WITH THE
SERGEANT THE MAKE SURE WE GET
THAT.
EXCELLENT RIGHT AND THEN THE
INTERNET CHAU WE SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE.
I DO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL -- SKEWS
ME ACTION MY NAME IS CARL DOG I
TO HIM FROM ART ARCADE ON IN
CORPORATE AREAS STOCK NO COUNTY.
AND I REALLY FEEL WE NEED TO BE
EMPOWERED AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL WHOLEHEARTEDLY THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
YEAH MY NAME IS SEAN DILLON I'M
FROM COMICAL AND INCORPORATES
MANY OF SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
RESIDENTS INSECT ACCOUNTING FIRM
IN SUPPORT OF HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S JOHN TOMENTUM FROM
SALINAS WELL WE HAVE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
AND I REPRESENTS COMMUNITY AS
WELL AS A CHAMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PAMELA
MILLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THERE'S BEEN NO INCORPORATION --
SINCE THE VLF WAS TAKEN AWAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KATHY STRICKLAND I TO
LIVE IN ARDEN ARCADE I AM THE
HISTORIAN THERE -- AND I WOULD I
I TRULY TRULY HOPE YOU WILL HELP
US MOVE THIS FORWARD OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND ON TO A VOTE.
IT MEANS SO MUCH TO US TO HAVE
OUR OWN VOICE IN OUR OWN PLACE
BREAKING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE SINCE THE SUPPORT.
SIGNAL IT -- SEEING NONE OF
THOSE IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE -- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OUR COMMENTS.
OKAY I'D LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY GIVE A CLOSING STATEMENT A
QUESTION I VOTE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE WITNESSES I WANT
TO FIRST THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD I SUPPORT THE
ABILITY OF COMMUNITIES TO
INCORPORATE WHERE AN APPROPRIATE
IN THIS BILL WILL.
HELP INSURE INCORPORATION IS A
VIABLE OPTION MOVING FORWARD.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU THAT
TOOK THE TIME TODAY TO COME UP
AND TESTIFY IT MEANS A LOT TO US
ON THE COMMITTEE WE KNOW IT
TAKES TIME OUT OF YOUR DAY TO DO
THIS.
AND TO BE AS SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT -- WE'LL TAKE THE ROLE OF
THE ROLE PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I'D LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I'D CHIU ROMMEL'S.
RAMOS I THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
VOEPEL.
YES THE GUY VOEPEL I BILLS OUT
FIVE ZERO CONGRATULATIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
BERMAN SIX YOUR TIME
.
ALL RIGHT WE CAN TAKE A LITTLE
BREAK HERE WAITING FOR AUTHORS
THAT OTHER COMMITTEES RIGHT NOW
SO IF EVERYBODY COULD HOLD ON
WE'RE HOPING THEY'LL -- JOIN US
SHORTLY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
PERFECT TIMING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
SEVEN FOUR SEVEN WELCOME MR
LEVINE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING.
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
SAYS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS EIGHTY
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN WILL REQUIRE
THE SAFETY ELEMENT OF A CITY OR
COUNTY GENERAL PLAN. TO INCLUDE
ADDRESSES OF EVACUATION ROUTES
AND THEIR CAPACITY UNDER RANGE
OF EMERGENCY SCENARIOS.
CALIFORNIA FACES THE DAUNTING
TASK OF RESPONDING TO PROLONG
WILDFIRE SEASONS NATURAL
DISASTERS AND THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
AB SEVEN FORTY SEVEN REQUIRES
COMMUNITIES TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR SUFFICIENT
EVACUATION ROUTE CAPACITY.
DURING A FULL SCALE EMERGENCY
AND WILL HELP SAVE THE LIVES OF
MANY IN THE EVENT OF A DISASTER.
HERE TWO STEPS BEHIND SUPPORT IS
LAUREN TO VALENCIA YOU SANCHEZ
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LAUREN TABLE AND SEE I
REPRESENT THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WITH THE
AMENDMENTS -- REALLY APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND COMMITTEE STAFF TO CLARIFY --
WITHIN AT THIS SAFETY ELEMENTS
WHO WITHIN THAT -- WOULD IT BE
THE PLANNERS WOULD BE THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNERS HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANNERS -- WOULD BE
ACTUALLY DOING THE EVALUATION OF
THIS DOCUMENT EITHER WAY MAKING
SURE THAT IT'S INCORPORATED INTO
THE SAFETY ELEMENT AND THEN ALSO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENT THAT
ALLOWS THAT THOSE AGENCIES WHO
HAVE ALREADY DONE SOMETHING
SIMILAR IN A SIMILAR DOCUMENT
CAN SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLY WITH
THE BILL -- INCORPORATE THAT AS
WELL SO PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NOT.
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
HERE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AMBER DRU LIKE TO CLOSE IT'S
JUST A PLEASURE TO BE BACK IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THIS MORNING
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
IT'S BEEN LIKE FIVE YEARS SINCE
I WAS ON THE COMMITTEE SO I JUST
LIKE TO IT REALLY BRINGS ME BACK
DO YOU MISS IT.
NOW.
SO -- FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR COULD MY STAFF TO
FLUSH OUT SOME THE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES WITH THE
BILL THAT WE THOUGHT.
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONSUMMATE
THINK THIS IS THIS ADDITION TO
SAFETY ELEMENT IS VERY VERY
NECESSARY A LOT OF THE HER
HORRIFIC FIRES IN THE FALL.
I'D I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR AND THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU YEAH.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY I
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I'D TO RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE A LOSE REVISTA ROBERT
RIVAS VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
FIVE ZERO MR SUBSTITUTE CHAIR
MISTER LEVINE [inaudible]
THE HOME.
I'VE OBVIOUSLY GOT A LOT OF WORK
TO DO HERE WE DON'T HAVE ANY OUT
THERE SO WE'RE JUST GONNA KICK
BACK FOR A COUPLE OF MINUTES.
TELL STORIES
.
ALL RIGHT WILL CONTINUE -- GOOD
AFTERNOON WE HAVE NO AB TWO
TWELVE ITEM NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY
APOLOGIES TO THE CHAIR AND A
COLLEAGUES FOR THE DELAY WE GET
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE A QUICK.
ONE THIS IS A. B. AT TWO TWELVE
AND I WANNA.
THANK THE CHAIR FOR THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS I AGREE TO ADOPT THEM
THANK YOU FOR THOSE [inaudible]
EN.
THIS IS THE BILL THAT WILL HELP
MODERNIZE HOW.
ARE COUNTY RECORDER'S PRESERVE
AND STORE DOCUMENTS SO THAT THEY
CAN USE TECHNOLOGIES BEYOND
MICROPHONE.
IN USE A MODERN TECHNOLOGIES
LIKE CLOUD COMPUTING STORAGE
ELECTRONIC DATA IMAGING IT'LL BE
A PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
USE EXISTING FUNDS -- TO
PRESERVE OUR CENTRAL DOCUMENTS
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE AVAILABLE
TO US IN THE FUTURE.
I WANT TO THANK.
YOU MEMBERS I AM YOU OFFER YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE -- WITH ME IN
SUPPORT IS LESS THE MARGEN THE
SHASTA COUNTY RECORDER.
WELCOME I THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
BEING HERE GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS HE SAID
LESLIE MARKET ON THE SHASTA
COUNTY ASSESSOR RECORDER.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY RECORDER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WAS RECORDERS WE HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO TO NOT ONLY
EXAMINE A RECORD DOCUMENTS BUT
THE STORE THOSE INTO PERPETUITY --
IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT ON THE FRONT
IN WERE MAKING SURE ONLY THE
CORRECT DOCUMENTS ARE BEING
RECORDED.
THE ALMOST THE MORE NEAR AND
DEAR TO ALL OF OUR HEARTS IS THE
ABILITY TO KEEP THEM FOR EVER
FOR OUR ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
ALL THE CITIZENS.
SO WITH THAT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
WHEN THE DOLLAR FEE WAS
IMPLEMENTED OF COURSE IT WAS
WRITTEN AROUND THE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT EXISTED THAT BEING
MICROFILM ESSENTIALLY MICROGRAPH
X. MICROFILM.
AND WE'VE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN RECORDING OUR DOCUMENTS
UTILIZING THOSE METHODS BUT
OBVIOUSLY AS TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
OVER TIME.
IT'S JUST NO LONGER THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT WAY
FOR US TO DO THAT.
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO USE
THOSE FUNDS -- TO MORE
APPROPRIATELY STORE THE
DOCUMENTS INTO THE FUTURE FOR
FOR ALL OF THE CITIZENS.
GREAT THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PEOPLE IN WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY --
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
NO.
IN A TIME LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
BONTA.
JUST TO SAY THAT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE BILL THAT WILL
UPDATE MODERNIZE CURRENT LAW TO
ADDRESS OUR CURRENT NEEDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD AND CARING RECORD
STORAGE TECHNOLOGY INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY IMAGINE
THAT.
ALL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS
AMENDED LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
HOW TO IMPLEMENT IT IN THE YEARS
AGO GO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TRAVELS FROM THE SHASTA KENNEDY
HERE TO TESTIFY.
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
I TO RAMOS.
A SIGH.
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT
RIVAS I'VE VOEPEL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MAKE.
MEASURES UP BY SIX ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
SURE.
OUR UP FOR ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
TWELVE NINETY THREE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REAVIS.
EXCUSE ME THAT WOULD BE FIFTY
THREE IF YOU WANT TO DO NINETY
THREE YOUNGER HALL.
WELCOME MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
RUNNING UP AND DOWN THE STAIRS I
AM OUT OF BREATH AND OUT OF
SHAPE.
SO -- BUT I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE --
WITH ALL OF YOU AND I HIT A
PRESENT SENATE BILL.
TWELVE FIFTY THREE A GOOD
GOVERNMENT BILL SEEKING TO
IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCIES IN THE
DELIVERY OF MUNICIPAL SERVICES.
SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY THREE LAUGH
GOES LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSIONS HAVE OPERATED IN ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING
IMPORTANT STATUTORY DIRECTIVES
TO TO MAINTAIN ORDERLY
BOUNDARIES AND SEEK GREATER
EFFICIENCIES AND THE DELIVERY OF
LOCAL SERVICES.
AB TWELVE FIFTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE GRANT
FUNDING TO LAUGH GOES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THE COMMUNITIES TO SIGNIFICANTLY
LACK THE FINANCIAL ABILITY TO
FINANCE IMPORTANT LAUGHTER
ACTIVITIES.
AND MEET OR ACCOMPLISH STATUTORY
DIRECTIVES.
NOT HAVING MYSELF BEEN A MEMBER
OF LAUGH GO FOR NUMBER OF YEARS
DURING MY TIME AS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR.
I CAN SHARE WITH YOU MY
EXPERIENCES OF THE CHALLENGES WE
ENCOUNTERED AS A LAUGH GO FROM A
SMALLER COUNTY.
OR ON A DISTRICT.
ARE FUNDING LIMITATIONS A
CONSTRAINT ABSOLUTELY IMPACTED
OUR ABILITY TO INITIATE PLANS TO
CONSIDER STUDIES IN OPTIONS --
TO CREATE LOCAL EFFICIENCIES AND
ULTIMATELY ELIMINATE WASTE.
SO AS DETAILED IN THE ANALYSIS
THE GRANT PROGRAM ESTABLISHED --
THROUGH THIS BILL WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL -- AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES WOULD INCLUDE
ADOPTING PROGRAM GUIDELINES
TIMELINES APPLICATION AND
REPORTING CRITERIA FOR PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION --
SO WITH ME.
HERE THIS AFTERNOON IS SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN
CURRENT LAUGH GO COMMISSIONER
JOHN LEOPOLD.
AND ALSO WITH THIS IS PAMELA
MILLER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AGENCY FORMATION COMMISSION.
THANK YOU MANAGER WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- PAMELA MILLER
WITH CAL ASCO I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
SO THIS COMMITTEE KNOWS ALL TOO
WELL -- GIVEN THE LARGE NUMBER
OF LAUGHTER BILLS THAT YOU SEEN
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS -- THAT
LAUGH COAST ARE UNDER GROWING
CRITICISM. FOR NOT INITIATING
ACTION TO CREATE GREATER
EFFICIENCIES OR ADDRESSING
EXISTING ISSUES IN THE DELIVERY
OF LOCAL SERVICES.
SO WHILE THERE IS ACTION BY
LAUGH BECAUSE IN BY DISTRICTS --
EVIDENCE SHOWS MORE CAN BE DONE.
THIS BILL WAS BEFORE YOU LAST
YEAR BUT IT LOOKED A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT -- WE TOOK AMENDMENTS
FROM THIS COMMITTEE WE TOOK
AMENDMENTS IN SENATE GOV IN
FINANCE AS WELL AS NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER.
AND NEGOTIATED A COMPROMISE ON
THE PROTEST THRESHOLDS WITH CSTA
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. TO WHAT YOU SEE IN
THE BILL TODAY.
AND AS A RESULT LAST YEAR THEY
MOVED FROM -- OPPOSED TO SUPPORT.
THE BILL MADE IT ALL THE WAY TO
THE GOVERNOR'S DESK LAST YEAR
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WAS VETOED.
BUT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
RESOURCE FOR LEFT COAST SO WE
ARE ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT ONCE
AGAIN.
AND I WANT TO SHARE JUST FOR A
MOMENT THE REALITY OF LIFE
BECAUSE IT AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REAVIS HAS ALREADY.
SHARED WITH YOU HIS EXPERIENCE
AND SUPERVISOR LEOPOLD WILL
SHARE HIS IN SANTA CRUZ.
THE BILL ANALYSIS SITE SOME
LASKO BUDGET DATA -- AND THE
REALITY IS WHEN YOU'RE LASKO HAS
AN ANNUAL BUDGET OF UNDERTWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
47% OF THE LEFT BECAUSE STATE
WHY DO.
IN FACT 30% HAVE LESS THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR BUDGET.
AND YOU HAVE AN ANNUAL WORK PLAN
TO FOLLOW A TO MEET ALL THE
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS FOR LASKO
IN YOUR SOURCE OF REVENUE IS
HIGHLY LIMITED.
THERE IS LITTLE TO NO ROOM TO
TAKE IN DEPTH LOOK AT AREAS WERE
SERVICE EFFICIENCIES CAN BE
GAINED.
SERVICE EFFICIENCIES THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY PROVIDE A STREAM
LINED.
OF AND COST EFFECTIVE WAY OF
DELIVERING QUALITY SERVICES.
THERE'S ALSO A LITTLE TO NO
FINANCING ROOM TO INITIATE
ACTION IS A LAUGH ACOSTA ABSORB
ALL OF THE COSTS IN THOSE CASES.
AND THESE ARE ISSUES ARE
SPECIALLY TRUE AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WHICH IS THE FOCUS
OF THE BILL.
THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS LAUGH KERN
ISSUED ACTIONS ONLY DURING THIS
FIVE YEAR PERIOD AND PERTAINING
TO THIS PROGRAM. TO HAVE
PROTESTS THRESHOLDS THAT REFLECT.
PROTEST THAT THAT REFLECT THE
ELECTIONS CODE RELATED TO RECALL
ELECTIONS WHICH IS A TIERED
APPROACH.
THE THRESHOLD TO PRESERVE THE
PUBLIC'S RIGHT TO PROTEST ACTION
AND TO HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD.
THIS TIERED APPROACH IS MORE
PROPORTIONATE TO THE POPULATION
AND THE POPULATION OF A
REGISTERED VOTERS THAN A FLAT
10% OR FLAT 25%.
AND THIS CHANGE ONLY APPLIES TO
POTENTIAL ACTIONS TAKEN RELATED
TO THIS SPECIAL GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH IS DESIGNED FOR LAUGH
BECAUSE TO ADDRESS KNOWN SERVICE
AND GOVERNANCE CONCERNS
IDENTIFIED IN A PREVIOUS
MUNICIPAL SERVICE REVIEW.
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT --
KNOWN SERVICE ISSUES THE BERWICK
THE BILL CLEARLY STATES THAT
THERE MUST BE DOCUMENTED SERVICE
CONCERNS PREVIOUSLY IDENTIFIED
IN AN MSR.
AS A QUALIFICATION TO APPLY FOR
THESE GRANT FUNDS THAT MEANS
THAT LAUGH BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GO WHY OLD -- THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO GO OFF THE DEEP END --
THE THE WITH -- WITH TRYING TO
INITIATE ACTION.
THIS BILL IS A GOOD STEP IN
PROVIDING LEFT BECAUSE THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO DO WITH THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ASKED THEM TO DO
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
LEOPOLD A MEMBER OF THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
ON THE COMMISSION ARE ON THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION.
AND I'M PAST CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LAUGH
GOES THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO LISTEN TO MY TESTIMONY
AND FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AB.
TWELVE FIFTY THREE I ALSO WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVERSE
FOR AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
OVER MY TEN YEARS ON OUR
COUNTIES LAUGHTER WE HAVE DONE A
NUMBER OF MUNICIPAL SERVICE
REVIEWS ARE MS OURS THAT
APPOINTED TO AREAS WHERE SERVICE
PROVIDERS COULD GAIN
EFFICIENCIES AND SERVICE.
ABOUT A DOZEN YEARS AGO WE USED
ALL OF OUR SPECIAL STUDIES FUNDS
TO LOOK AT FIRE DISTRICTS COUNTY
WIDE AT A COST OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
OUR STUDY POINTED TO AREAS WERE
CONSOLIDATION OF SERVICES OR
MERGERS MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO
IMPROVE THE FINANCIAL PICTURE A
LONG TERM VIABILITY OF SERVICES.
WE HELD HEARINGS -- WHEN
PRESENTED TO EVERY FIRE DISTRICT
AND FOUND THAT NONE OF THE FIRE
DISTRICTS EVEN WHEN PRESENTED
WITH THIS INFORMATION WERE
INTERESTED IN MAKING THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CHANGES TO THEIR
DISTRICT?
IN OUR LAST ROUND OF MSR AS WE
DID NOT INTEND TO DO A DETAILED
STUDY OF EACH FIRE DISTRICT
GIVEN THE RESPONSE OF THE
PREVIOUS ROUTE PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED.
BUT UNLIKE BEFORE ONE OF THE
DISTRICT TOLD US THEY WERE READY
TO SERIOUSLY LOOK AT THIS ISSUES.
THE DISTRICT CONTAINS A SIZEABLE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY AND
COUNTS ON THE FIRE DISTRICT FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE
NEIGHBORING FIRE DISTRICT AND
FOUND INTEREST THERE AS WELL.
AT LEAST ONE BOARD WAS READY TO
GO AND BOTH FIRE JESTER COULD
JUST LIKE OTHER FIRE CHIEFS
PRESENTING A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLEAR THE HURDLES THAT
USUALLY STAND IN THE WAY.
OF THESE DISCUSSIONS WE HAD GOOD
INTEREST BUT LOW FUNDS TO
CONDUCT A STUDY THAT CAN LEAD TO
BETTER SERVICES AND FINANCIAL
STABILITY FOR THESE FIRE
DISTRICTS.
THE REASON THAT THE FIRE
DISTRICT WERE INTERESTED WAS DUE
TO THE INCREASING COSTS IN
OPERATION OUR LOCAL LASKO
HOWEVER HAD SPENT MOST OF OUR
SPECIAL STUDY REVENUE.
ON ARE LOOKING AT PARKS AND
SANITATION DISTRICT WHICH IS
ALSO OUR RESPONSIBILITIES SO WE
FACED A CROSSROADS.
IF WE HAD A GRANT PROGRAM LIKE
THE ONE ENVISIONED IN AB TWELVE
FIFTY THREE THE CHOICE WOULD
HAVE BEEN CLEAR.
THROUGH A SUCCESSFUL APPLICATION
WE COULD STUDY THE ISSUES OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SERVICE DELIVERY
SALARY AND BENEFITS PARITY A
LONG TERM PERSONAL BENEFITS.
A STUDY LIKE THIS WOULD COST
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WOULD TAX THE BUDGET
OF ALL THE THREE AGENCIES -- IF
WE HAD TO DO IT OURSELVES.
OF THE TOP REASON THAT LAUGH
BECAUSE DO NOT INITIATE ACTIONS
TO IMPROVE SERVICES IS THE LACK
OF LACK OF FUNDING ALWAYS
FEATURED PROMINENTLY.
AS MUCH.
AS PAMELA MENTIONED THE 47% OF
OUR LAUGH GOES HAVE AN ANNUAL
BUDGET.
OF UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR SO YOU CAN SEE
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT FOR THESE
KIND OF STUDIES.
WHAT HAVE OUR LOCAL LAUGH GOES?
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
RARELY RECOMMENDS FUNDING TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS BUT FORTUNATELY
SAW THAT A SMALL ONE TIME
INFUSION OF OF FUNDS -- FOR THIS
GRANT PROGRAM COULD POTENTIALLY
SAVE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ADDITIONAL MONEY IF IT LEADS TO
STREAMLINE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
IMPROVED EFFICIENCY AND SERVICE
DELIVERY.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS SOMETIMES.
BEEN FRUSTRATED WITH THE SLOW
AND DELIBERATIVE LAUGH GO
PROCESSES AND INTRODUCED BILLS
THAT WOULD TAKE AWAY LOCAL
ANALYSIS OF ISSUES SUCH AS THE
CONSOLIDATION OF SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
TODAY I ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWELVE FIFTY THREE TO PROVIDE
THE ONLY FUNDING WE WOULD GET
FROM THE STATE TO CONDUCT OUR
STATE MANDATED RESPONSIBILITIES
AND HELP US CONDUCT THESE
STUDIES AND IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY IS A SPECIAL DISTRICT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THROUGH THIS LEGISLATION WE CAN
KEEP THE DECISION MADE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT IS THE BEST
PLACE TO RESOLVE COMPLICATED
ISSUES OF MERGERS AND
CONSOLIDATION.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST -- I BUILT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THAT HEAD ON COLLISION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
ANTHONY TAMIL WITH CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
IN SUPPORT OUT ONE I THINK THE
WHOLE LAUGHTER TEAM WORKING WITH
US LAST YEAR SO HERE ON AROUND
TOO WE CAN INTO THE ASTOR KLAY
SAY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DO A KERRY FULLY CALIFORNIA'S
RESULTS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ELIZABETH ESPINOSA HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU.
Q. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR WELL
ENOUGH MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS CHRIS ANDERSON I'M ON
BEHALF OF ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES -- I
WANNA PREFACE MY COMMENTS BY
SAYING THAT WERE NOT A PART WE
HAVE A POSITION OF NOT OPPOSE
PROPOSED UNLESS AMENDED -- BUT
OUR BUT I DOES NOT CONCERN
ESTABLISHING THE GRANT PROGRAM
RATHER OUR OPPOSITION.
IT ADDRESSES THE PROTEST
THRESHOLD IN THE BILL UNDER
EXISTING LAW WHEN I LAUGHED --
INITIATES AN ORGANIZATION A
REORGANIZATION -- A THAT THAT
ORGANIZATION THAT ACTION.
USE THE MICROPHONE YES.
SORRY ABOUT THAT [inaudible]
THAT ACTION.
MUST BE SUBMITTED TO THE VOTERS
IF.
AT LEAST 10 OF REGISTERED
VOTERS.
PROTEST THE PROPOSED ACTION THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE A DUPLICATE OF
PROTEST THRESHOLD -- A TIERED
PROTEST THRESHOLD THAT WOULD FOR
THE EXACT SAME LASKO INITIATED
ACTION SO OUR BELIEF IS THAT
THIS WOULD CONFUSE EXISTING LAW
AND ALSO MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT --
FOR AFFECTED REGISTERED VOTERS
IN AFFECTED TERRITORIES.
TO PROTEST.
LASKO INITIATED ACTION.
IN ADDITION WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TWO ADDITIONAL WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TO AMENDMENTS.
ONE WOULD BE TO EXEMPT PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES FROM THIS BILL
THAT WOULD THAT THEORY IS BASED
ON THE FACT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
IS GIVEN THE STATE WATER BOARD.
THE ABILITY TO CONSOLIDATE AND
EXTEND SERVICE TO AREAS THAT.
ARE CURRENTLY IS SERVED BY
AGENCIES THAT FAILED TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER AND THE
OTHER AND THEN AT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS A PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS WHEN CAL
LASKO AND MEN AND AT THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
DISCUSS THE GUIDELINES AND
CRITERIA FOR THIS -- APPLICATION.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- HIS STAFF -- AND CAL
LASKO FOR CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH US ABOUT THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
DENNIS ALBION AB HALF OF MESA
WATER COSTA MESA CALIFORNIA WE
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS HE DID A
EXCELLENT JOB CHRIS DID FROM
AQUA.
AND LOCALLY IT IS AN ORANGE
COUNTY THERE ARE.
FOLKS THAT DO TO VIEW SOMETIMES
VIEW -- GOVERNMENT A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL AND THE ISSUE WITH THE
DIFFERENT THRESHOLDS.
WE THINK IT FRANKLY DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MAKE SENSE TO HAVE
THE TIERED THRESHOLDS I KEEP IT
ONE STANDARD -- YOU KNOW THE
KNOX CORTESE HERTZBERG ACTING
WHEN THE HERTZBERG WAS ADDED TO
IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIS WAS A WELL
NEGOTIATED.
OF THRESHOLD THAT WAS WITH THAT
WAS APPROVED AND WE THINK IT'S
BEST TO MAINTAIN THE EXISTING
THRESHOLD.
AND GO FROM THERE I THINK WILL
HELP.
AS FOLKS AS PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
USED FOR THESE GRANTS TO TO DO
THESE IN ADDRESS AN ACTIVE --
ENTITIES AS WELL AS OTHER --
CONSOLIDATIONS THAT IT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE A BIG YOU KNOW POWER
GRAB WITH SOME PUBLIC FUNDS AND
SO I THINK AND AGAIN NOT THAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO.
JUST THAT'S THE PERCEPTION OF
SOMETIMES SO IT IS ESPECIALLY IN.
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE STATE.
SO WE THINK THE THRESHOLD TO SAY
THE SAME AND THEN WILL BE THE
THE STANDARDIZED VIEW THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER IN QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL
[inaudible]
SO.
THE CORE POINTS OF THIS.
THE BILL MAKES SENSE TO ME AND I
SUPPORT [inaudible]
BUT THE PROTEST THRESHOLDS.
HI I WOULD LIKE TO ASK -- THE
LEFT CO PEOPLE.
WHY NOT LEAVE IT A 10% BY MONKEY
WITH IT MAKE IT TWENTY FIVE OR
THIRTY OR WHATEVER -- I DON'T
GET THAT PART OF IT.
THROUGH THE CHAIR IF I MAY.
UM SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
THE THE SO SUPERVISOR LEOPOLD
HAD MENTIONED A FUNDING WAS ONE
OF THE MAJOR DETERRENCE FOR
LAUGH CO TO INITIATE ACTION.
BECAUSE WHEN LAUGH BECAUSE
INITIATE THE ACTION THEY AND IN
ESSENCE BECOME THE APPLICANTS
AND THEY HAVE TO PAY ALL OF
THOSE FEES.
ANOTHER MAJOR DETERRENT.
OF FOR LAUGH CLOSE TO INITIATE
ACTION IS THE DESPAIR AT
PROTESTS THRESHOLD -- AND IF I
COULD -- RESPOND TO ONE OF THE
OPPONENTS COMMENTS ABOUT THE
WELL NEGOTIATED A 10% VERSUS 25%
THERE IS A A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY ABOUT WHY THEY ARE THE
WAY THEY ARE.
AND SO THERE 25% WAS PUT IN
PLACE MANY MANY.
YEARS AGO FOR NON LAUGH CONUS
SHADED ACTIONS.
IT WAS BACK IN I BELIEVE
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WHEN LAUGH
COAST ACTUALLY WERE GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY TO INITIATE ACTION IT
WAS THROUGH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GOTCH OF RAN A BILL.
AND THE ORIGINAL BILL HAD 25% AS
THE THRESHOLD SO IT MIRRORED
EXISTING STATUTE.
COME.
UP AS WE KNOW HOW THINGS GO WHEN --
WHEN THEY GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE?
THAT WAS NEGOTIATED DOWN 210%.
AN ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS WERE
PLACED ON LAUGH KOS IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY INITIATE ACTION
THAT DON'T EXIST FOR NON LAUGHED
WHEN SHE DID ACTION.
AT THAT AT THAT POINT IT WAS
NEGOTIATED DOWN A BECAUSE FOLKS
WERE AFRAID AGAIN THAT LAUGH
BECAUSE WE'RE JUST GOING TO GO
WILD WITH.
INITIATING ACTIONS AND THE
REALITY IS THAT -- COOK NOTHING
COULD BE FARTHER FROM THE TRUTH
I MEAN THERE PROCESSES IS
DELIBERATE IT'S BEEN CREATED
THAT WAY BY THE LEGISLATURE --
AND OUT SO -- WHEN THE WHEN THE?
THE OF LEVEL IS 10% OF IT IT IS
A HUGE DETERRENT.
AND SO -- WHAT?
OR WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING IS FOR
PURPOSES OF THIS GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT IT BE TIERED AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF.
IF WE USE THE ELECTION CODE THAT
IS BEING USED IF YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED A HUNDRED THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS.
I WANNA MAKE SURE I'M I'M
GETTING THIS A 100% ACCURATE I
HAVE HERE WITH ME.
SO IF.
IF THE REGISTER EFFORT IF
THERE'S LESS THAN A THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS THE THRESHOLD
WOULD BE 30% AND IT IT IT TEARS
FROM THERE.
AND IF THERE'S A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE REGISTERED
VOTERS THAN THE LEVEL IS 10% SO
CLEARLY THE LARGER THE COMMUNITY
THE LARGER THE PROTESTS
THRESHOLD IS [inaudible]
MAY I SO YOU SAID IT WAS A
DETERRENT.
A DETERRENT TO WHO.
SO -- IF FOR THE LAUGH CO TO
INITIATE ACTION.
ALL I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE --
ONE OF ONE EXAMPLE IS -- IN ONE
OF THE A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES THE LAUGHTER WAS
LOOKING AT A NUMBER OF A FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICTS.
OF FOR CONSOLIDATION AND THEY
HAD DONE A MUNICIPAL SERVICE
REVIEW AND THEY HAD ALL THE THE
BACKUP MATERIAL.
AND THEY WERE CONSIDERING --
INITIATING A CONSOLIDATION OF
THESE FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICTS.
THERE THEY WERE VERY VERY SMALL
AND SO THE THRESHOLD -- TO ANISH
TO TRIGGER AN ELECTION WOULD
HAVE BEEN ONE HUNDRED SIGNATURES
OR PROTESTS -- ANNA TO REACH THE
10% THRESHOLD.
SO THE LEFT -- REALIZED THAT --
THAT WITH THIS SUCH A SMALL
COMMUNITY THEY KNEW THAT.
IT.
IT WOULD FAIL.
AND O THE LAUGH CO IS THE ONE
THAT INITIATES THE ACTION THEY
PUT ALL OF THEIR OWN RESOURCES
NOBODY FUNDS IT IT COMES OUT OF
THIS SMALL LAUGH CHO BUDGET. TO
PROCESS THE APPLICATION TO TO DO
THE ELECTION ALL OF THOSE THINGS
AND SO -- WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING
FOR A LITTLE A LITTLE LENIENCY
THEIR IF I COULD MAKE ONE MORE
COMMENT ABOUT THE PROTEST.
THIS LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
REPORT THAT WE'VE ALL A YOU KNOW
HEARD ABOUT -- THAT WE WE'VE
LIVED FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW --
THEY MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO LAUGH
CO AND ONE OF THEM WAS REGARDING.
THE PROTEST THRESHOLDS -- WE
HAVE GATHERED A GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE ARE FORMING
RIGHT NOW.
A WORKING GROUP OF TO TAKE A AT
LEAST A TWO YEAR LOOK.
AT THE UP AT THE CURRENT PROTEST
PROCESS SEES AND THE THRESHOLDS
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE A VERY
CONVOLUTED.
UP -- BUT WE FEEL THAT -- THAT
IS OF SEPARATE AND APART THAT
THE THAT THIS ACTION THIS GRANT
PROGRAM THIS FUNDING -- AT AND
WHAT'S CONTAINED IN THE PROGRAM
IS SEPARATE FROM.
THAT FULL REVIEW.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR I HAVE NO
OTHER QUESTIONS MAY I MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT.
SURE THANK YOU.
SOAP HERE'S WHAT I HAVE TROUBLE
WITH GOING TO THE TIERED --
TWENTY FIVE OR 30% EXCEPT --
OVER 10%.
LEFT GO MAY HAVE A TIGHT BUDGET
I I GET THAT.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER REVERSE I
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM AND I SUPPORT ALMOST
I SUPPORTED ALL ALL EXCEPT FOR
THE 10% HERE'S WHY.
YOU HAVE A TIGHT BUDGET.
OKAY [inaudible]
CITIZENS.
THAT ARE PROTESTING A CHANGE TO
THEIR LITTLE WORLDS OR THEIR BIG
WORLD'S DEPENDING UPON.
THE POPULATION LEVEL.
THEY SHOULD HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO PROTEST AT THE
10% LEVEL BECAUSE YOU GOT MONEY
THEY DON'T.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO ORGANIZE
A CITIZEN PROTEST WITHOUT MONEY
UNLESS THERE'S SOME OUTSIDE
MONEY.
SO YOU HAVE A TREMENDOUS
ADVANTAGE TO ME -- THE 10% LEVEL
IS FAIR.
THEY HAVE A CHANCE.
AND I WAS MAYOR OF A CITY FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS.
AND WE DID A LOT OF BUSINESS
WITH LAUGH CO AND ON A FEW
OCCASIONS THE CITIZENS REVOLTED.
AND LOST ONE OUT OF TWO OKAY
THAT I RECOLLECT.
SO THE POINT I'M MAKING IS.
GREAT BILL EVERYTHING BUT
CHANGING THE 10% IS THERE ANY
WAY THERE COULD BE AN AMENDMENT
ON THAT.
ONE AND I'M DONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SO I'M IN A SO MANY ENTERTAIN A
MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS YOU KNOW
I DO APPRECIATE -- YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE THE
TIERED APPROACH FOR TRACK THE
FOR FOR THE PROTEST YOU KNOW THE
THAT THAT THRESHOLD WE BELIEVE
THAT YOU KNOW IT IS A LOGICAL
ONE THEY STILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTEST -- BUT
CERTAINLY WE CAN YOU KNOW
EXPLORE YOU KNOW -- THE OPTION
BUT CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A BILL THAT
ADDRESSES A NEED YOUR GOAL LONG
WAY IN THE TO SUPPORT SMALLER
LAP GO DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- IT AGAIN FROM MY
EXPERIENCE AS A LAUGH GO
COMMISSIONER FROM A SMALL COUNTY
YEAH I KNOW FROM FIRST HAND --
THAT LAUGH GOES ACROSS THE STATE
AND SMALLER DISTRICTS ESPECIALLY
THOSE SERVING DISADVANTAGED --
THE COMMUNITIES LACK THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO MAKE
CHANGES CHANGES NECESSARY TO
ENHANCE SERVICES THE DELIVERY
CREATE EFFICIENCIES -- THE
MANAGER THANK YOU -- AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I WORK
WITH LIFE GOES FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AS WELL.
THE MY FRUSTRATION WAS ALWAYS
THE LACK OF FUNDING FOR YOU TO
MOVE THINGS ALONG.
AND SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY -- I APPRECIATE IT'S
TAKEN A LONG TIME FOR THESE
CONVERSATIONS OF THE TWO TIER
THING I APPRECIATE MR VOEPEL AS
A COMMENTS AS WELL.
BUT WE NEED TO GET SOME FUNDING
SO WE CAN GET THESE THINGS YOUR
WE ARE PROJECTS MOVING IN SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THAT FORD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TRIP ALL THE
WAY UP FROM SANTA CRUZ TO
TESTIFY THE TODAY WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
I'M WITHOUT DIXIE YOU US USING.
SECRETARY CREE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY LACKEY NO
BLOOM.
BLOOM I'D CHIU RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE A THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERTRIVERSIDE VOEPEL RESPECT
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
MEASURES THAT FIVE TO TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK.
NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE SEVEN YEAH
[inaudible]
SHARE.
YEAH HE'S BACK.
ITEM NUMBER SIX A CA.
ONE SHARE AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU --
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACA
ONE WILL LOWER THE NECESSARY
VOTER THRESHOLD FROM TWO THIRDS.
TO A 55% SUPERMAJORITY TO PROVE
LOCAL GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS
AND SPECIAL TAXES WHEN PROPOSED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SUPPORTABLE HOUSE SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
THIS IS A VOTE THRESHOLD THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY APPROVED FOR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ISSUE SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION BONDS.
THIS MEASURE GIVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A MORE REALISTIC
FINANCING OPTION TO FUND AN
INCREASE IN THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING.
AND TO ADDRESS THE NUMEROUS
LOCAL PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
CHALLENGES CITIES COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE FACING
EACH DAY.
IN THIS COMMITTEE.
WE ARE WELL AWARE OF THE MANY
MANY EXAMPLES STATEWIDE WHERE
BUILDINGS ARE FALLING APART.
ROADS ARE IN NEED OF REPAIR.
LIBRARIES AND PARKS ARE SCARCE
AND THE NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HAS REACHED A STAGGERING
LEVEL.
ACA ONE IS A TOOL FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT PROJECTS TO
PRIORITIZE. TO BE CLEAR.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL INCREASES
TAXES.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL REQUIRES A
JURISDICTION TO PROPOSE A
MEASURE TO ITS VOTERS.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES DO IS
PROVIDE A TOOL FOR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS TO HELP THEM
DECIDE HOW TO BESTSERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES?
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO PASS IT
OFF TO MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
FROM HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TYRONE BUCKLEY WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA PLEASE -- TO SUPPORT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL -- WE ALL
KNOW THAT OUR STATE IS MIRED IN
A HOUSING CRISIS ONE KEY
SOLUTION IS TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES.
AN ACA ONE HELPS US KNOCKED DOWN
ONE OF THE MANY BARRIERS THAT
OUR STATE MUST REMOVE TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EASIER TO
BUILD SO THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF RACE INCOME AGE.
CONTINUE TO CALL OUR STATE HOME.
HOUSING PRICES.
ARE DRIVING THE COSTS OUT OF
REACH FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AS A RESULT ONE IN
THREE HOUSEHOLDS CANNOT MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
WE ALL KNOW ACCORDING TO LATEST
REPORTS THAT DESPITE PASSAGE OF
RECENT WAS LEGISLATION AND BONDS
IN THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN HOUSING
PACKAGE AND BY THE VOTER STATE
FUNDING TODAY REMAINS WELL BELOW.
THE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
LEVELS UNDERMINING PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING THIS CRISIS.
ACA ONE PROVIDES A GREATER
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES THAT
WISH TO PUT.
THEIR OWN SKIN IN THE GAME AND
DO THEIR PART TO ADDRESS THE
STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS.
BY REDUCING THE VOTER THRESHOLD.
ADDITIONALLY THE VOTE AND AND
AND THE MEMBER MENTIONED THIS.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE VOTE THRESHOLD AN ACA ONE
WOULD PUT LOCAL HOUSING BONDS ON
THE SAME LEVEL AS LOCAL SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION -- WHICH ALSO
REQUIRES 55% IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE STATE SOUGHT VOTER
APPROVAL FOR RECENT HOUSING AND
PARKS ONES AT THE STATE LEVEL --
SOMETHING THAT HOUSING
CALIFORNIA HELP CHAMPION IN THE
VOTE REQUIREMENT WAS JUST A
SIMPLE MAJORITY.
I HAVE HEARD PERSONALLY FROM
LEADERSACROSS THE STATE IN
PLACES LIKE SANTA CRUZ
SACRAMENTO WEST SACRAMENTO.
THAT REDUCING THE THRESHOLD 55%
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO RAISE
INVESTMENT THEY NEED TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION OUR
MEMBERSHIP IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND SEES IT AS A KEY TOOL TO
SOLVING THE HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WE ARE DRIVERS.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHRISTY BOMB ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
POLICE TO BE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE.
A YOU KNOW OUR MEMBERS RESPOND
ALL KINDS OF DISASTERS -- IN THE
RESPONDING OUT OF FIRE WHO
HOUSES WHO THAT ARE DECADES OLD
MAYBE WE GET A NEW FIRE HOUSE
WHEN THERE'S A BRAND NEW
DEVELOPMENT BUT OTHER FIRE
HOUSES HAVE BEEN AROUND. FOR
DECADES AND DECADES THAT NEED
RETROFITTING AND ATTENTION.
OF IN ORDER TO SUPPORT THESE
FIREFIGHTERS I THINK THE
IMPORTANT POINT OF THIS MEASURE
IS.
THIS IS A QUESTION TO BE PUT TO
THE VOTERS THAT'S ALL WE'RE
ASKING TO DO IS. TO ASK THE
VOTERS WHAT THEY THINK ABOUT A
VOTE THRESHOLD CHANGE FROM TWO
THIRDS 255%.
BUT YOU'RE NOT RAISING ATTACKS
TODAY IN THIS VOTE YOU'RE
SUPPORTING YOUR COMMUNITIES TO
GO TO THEIR VOTERS.
THE PREVIOUS WITNESS SAID AND
HAVE A CONVERSATION WHAT MAKES
SENSE FOR THEIR COMMUNITY.
WHAT SHOULD DETERMINE?
WHEN YOU LEVY A TAX IN A
COMMUNITY OR ISSUE BONDED
INDEBTEDNESS SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY?
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THE BAKER WITH THEIR NATIVE SAYS
HIS FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT.
THAT SUPPORTS THIS MEASURE THANK
THERE'S BROAD SUPPORT FOR
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT OF THE KEY TO THAT IS
FUNDING THIS WILL HELP GET THAT
FUNDING APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SERRA FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT FOR LOCAL CONTROL
INVESTMENT IN LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND THE CREATION OF GOOD LOCAL
JOBS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND SINCE WE HAVE SO
MANY PEOPLE TESTIFYING ON THIS
IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
DOWN TO A FEW WORDS THAT WOULD
BE GREAT.
THANK YOU BYE BUT I KNOW YOU.
YES.
IT'S HARD TO ASK A LOBBYIST --
DIG HERE AGO LEE CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AMY BROWN REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF NAPA AND THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH IN SUPPORT.
A LUIS BONTA WE HAVE CALIFORNIA
BE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIN HAGENS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN OF HAVE A BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
LARA DAVID ONCE YOU'RE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MARILYN CHECK CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
CAN YOU DON'T HEAR AROUND WITH
THE STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND
SUPPORT.
DAVID JONES ABOUT CITY STOCK IN
ITS SUPPORT.
BRIAN GREGORY NAPA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR NAPA COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
ANTONIO FORWARD SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
BILL HAGENS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENTS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
MIKE DILLON ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIAL A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ANTHONY TANNER HOW CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
LARA NINE ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
HOUSING FEDERATION WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
FEDERAL BALBOA ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MARLENE DEMAND ON BEHALF OF THE
EAST BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
BARGAINS OFFICE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY CAMERI -- AND SUPPORT.
MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
AND SPORT.
MICHAEL HIM TELL THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION SPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
ROBINSON WAS SHOT YOU'RE INTO WE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA THE SAN MATTEO CITY
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS AND THE SOLANO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY ALL IN
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HAULING
MICHON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD IN THE CITY OF
GOLD LEADER IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLACE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION DAY CA.
ONE MEMBERS LET ME JUST START
AND REALLY JUST MAKE IT
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
A VOTE FREE CA ONE WILL MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO OWN
PROPERTY IT'LL MAKE IT MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR PEOPLE TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES.
AND IT WILL DIRECTLY HARM LOW
INCOME PEOPLE TO THE POTENTIAL
AUTHORIZATION OF HIGHER
REGRESSIVE SALES TAXES -- THIS
IS A MIDDLE CLASS TAX INCREASE
OR AUTHORIZATION THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO SOLVE
CALIFORNIA'S RECORD HIGH 20%
POVERTY RATE.
THERE'S BEEN NUMEROUS PPIS PP I
SEE POLLS DONE WITHIN THE LAST
YEAR FIRST OF ALL 62% OF
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CONTINUOUS SUPPORT
PROP.
THIRTEEN THERE IS MAJORITY
SUPPORT IN EVERY SINGLE
GEOGRAPHIC AREA OF CALIFORNIA
FOR MAINTAINING THE TWO THIRDS
VOTE FOR PERSONAL TAXES.
AND MEMBERS WITH GOOD REASON
PERSONAL TAXES ARE VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN THAT IT'S THE SAME
FLAT RATE AMOUNT THAT IMPACTS
EVERY SINGLE PROPERTY OWNER IN
THIS STATE.
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR INCOME IT
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR HOW SITES.
OKAY EXTREMELY REGRESSIVE TAX
AND I THINK THAT REALLY SPEAKS
TO WHY THE TWO THIRDS VOTE IS SO
IMPORTANT.
IN A QUOTE THAT'S OFTEN
ATTRIBUTED TO BENJAMIN FRANKLIN
YOU WAS FOND OF SAYING DEMOCRACY
IS TWO WOLVES AND A SHEEP.
DECIDING WHAT'S FOR DINNER.
IN THAT INSTANCE EVERYONE --
KNOW WHAT WHAT'S MEANT BY THAT
QUOTE RIGHT EVERYBODY VOTES BUT
ONLY PROPERTY OWNERS PAY.
THERE WAS A COMMENT THAT WAS
MADE AT THE PRESS CONFERENCE ON
A CA ONE TODAY -- REGARDING PROP
THIRTEEN PROTECTING A VOCAL
MINORITY.
AND MEMBERS THERE'S ONLY ABOUT
50% OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ACTUALLY OWNS THEIR OWN
HOMES.
AND I'M ONE OF THEM WE ARE
BASICALLY A MINORITY.
IN OTHER WORDS WE'RE THE SHEEP
THAT DON'T WANT TO GET EATEN BY
THE WOLVES POTENTIALLY ADDING
HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS TO PROPERTY
TAX BILLS. TO HIGHER PERSONAL
TAX.
NEXT POINT THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
LIMIT TO THE NUMBER OF BONDS OR
PERSONAL TAXES THE CAN BE PASSED
BY CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
AGAIN THE QUESTION NEEDS REPOSE
HOW DO HIGHER BONDS AND PERSONAL
TAXES EXCLUSIVELY AGAINST
PROPERTY OWNERS PROMOTE
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
AND THE ANSWER IS VERY SIMPLE
THEY DO NOT.
ALSO WE NEED TO QUESTION WHETHER
OR NOT LOWERING THE THRESHOLD IS
EVEN NECESSARY THERE HAVE BEEN
LITERALLY DOZENS OF TWO THIRDS
VOTE BONDS AND SPECIAL TAXES
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
IN THE STATE SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TEN WHAT IS IN
GENERAL ORANGE COUNTY OF ALL
PLACES PAST YOU TRANSPORTATION
SALES TAXES OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS.
WHEN YOU IF YOU LOOK BACK OVER
THE LAST THREE NOVEMBER
ELECTIONS THESE MEASURES BONDS
AND SALES TAXES AND PERSONAL
TAXES HAVE OVER A 50% TAX RATE?
PASS RATE SO IS IT DIFFICULT TO
PASS THESE MEASURES OF COURSE IS
IT IS IT IMPOSSIBLE ABSOLUTELY
NOT.
THESE CAN AND YOU PASS WITH A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED CALIFORNIA
IS TWENTY FIRST AND COMBINED
STATE AND LOCAL PER CAPITA
PROPERTY TAXES ACCORDING TO THE
TAX FOUNDATION EVEN WITH
PROPOSITION.
THIRTEEN OKAY WE WE ARE VERY
HIGH PROPERTY TAX STATE AND
THAT'S PRECISELY BECAUSE OF
THESE LOCAL BONDS IN PERSONAL
TAXES BEING APPROVED BY VOTERS
AND WHY WOULD HE MAKE THAT
PROCESS EASIER.
AND MEMBERS FINALLY IN CLOSING --
THE ARGUMENTS BEEN NAY HEY WE
SHOULD JUST LET THE VOTERS
DECIDE WHY CAN'T WE JUST LET THE
VOTERS DECIDE AND PUT IT ON THE
BALLOT.
AND THE FACT REMAINS THAT TWICE
IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS VOTERS
HAVE DECIDED MOST RECENTLY IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX PROPOSITION
EIGHTY EIGHT WAS ON THE BALLOT
BACK THEN.
THAT WAS A FIFTY DOLLAR PERSONAL
TAX INCREASE ON PRETTY MUCH ALL
PROPERTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WAS REJECTED WITH US
75% ABOUT.
REJECTED SEVENTY FIVE TO TWENTY
FIVE SO I THINK THE VOTERS HAVE
SPOKEN VERY VERY CARLY BOTH
RECENTLY AND AGAIN THROUGH THE
PPA SEE POLLS THAT THEY DON'T
WANT THIS THRESHOLD WORRIED SO
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS ASPIRIN
OVER.
OKAY FAHRRAD REPRESENTING
COALITION PRODUCT WITH SCHOOL
HOUSING.
I IN OUR LETTER WE WERE CLEAR --
WE WERE NOT ASKING FOR NOVELL
TODAY WERE IN THE PROPOSAL AS
AMENDED.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AND OUR STAFF.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
FROM A SCHOOL POINT OF VIEW.
HI.
WE ARE.
WANTING TO BE SURE ON THE
PROVISIONS THAT THERE'S A
UNDERSTANDING THAT UNDER TO
SCHOOL 55%.
WE HAVE A CAP ON THE AMOUNT OF
DEBT WE CAN ISSUE -- WE ALSO ARE
CAPPED ON OUR TAX RATE.
SO YOU WANT TO SEE IF WE CAN
HAVE THOSE TYPES OF DISCUSSIONS.
NOT IN THE CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT.
BECAUSE THAT'D BE TOO
RESTRICTIVE AND CONSTRAINING.
BUT IN SEPARATE STATUTE.
I WOULD SAY IF THE AMENDMENT
PASSES.
THAN SIMILAR TYPES OF PROVISIONS.
WOULD BE APPLICABLE.
OF FOR THIS 55% HAS ARE
APPLICABLE TO THE SCHOOL 55%.
SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS THESE ISSUES
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THAT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR TREES TO MAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE TEND TO THIS BILL
WE RESPECTFULLY MUST SUPPOSE WE
HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL.
NUMBER ONE IS THAT THIS BILL
COULD POTENTIALLY HARM THOSE
THAT IT INTENDS TO HELP.
BY FACILITATING TAX INCREASES ON
BOTH SALES AND PARCEL TAXES.
IT COULD POTENTIALLY INCREASE
THE COST OF HOUSING CONSTRUCTION.
SECONDARILY IT IMPOSES A TAX ON
THOSE WORKING FAMILIES THAT IT
THIS IS INTENDED TO HELP.
THE GOVERNOR AND HIS STATE OF
THE UNION ADDRESS WANTED TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA AFFORDABLE FOR ALL.
AND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THERE
MAY BE INADVERTENT CONSEQUENCES
AS A RESULT OF FACILITATING TAX
INCREASES.
ON WORKING FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR COMMENTS -- AND I I WANT TO
BE EVEN HANDED HERE SO -- I
ASKED -- FOR BRIEF COMMENTS --
FROM -- A PROPONENTS ANALYST FOR
THE SAME FROM OPPONENTS.
THANK YOU.
KAREN KLINGER LOCAL REAL ESTATE
BROKER I SEE THIS BILL AS
NOTHING BUT DISCRIMINATION.
AGAINST HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE PAID
CONSTANTLY FOR ADDED TAXES I'VE
HANDED THE GENTLEMAN TWO PAGES
OF TAXES THIS IS A
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BUY A HOME
BECAUSE CONVERSION HAS PARCEL
TAXES WERE ASKING YOU TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THEN IT'S ALL GONNA BE WE HAVE
THE FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATES
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS HIT OUR
COMMENT.
WITH CAL TAX AND THE OTHER FOLKS --
WE WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ONGOING TAXATION OF BUSINESS IS
LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
BUT DROUGHT COOK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
POST.
THANK YOU I DO HAVE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION.
MR TO MAKE THE MOTION AND HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS AND I'M.
PLEASED TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AS THE CHAIR
OF THE HOUSING COMMITTEE I THINK
WE ALL KNOW THAT -- WE'RE IN THE
MIDST OF THE MOST INTENSE
HOUSING CRISIS AND HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
AND LONG TERM WE ALL KNOW THAT
OUR STATE FACES A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
CRISIS.
AS WAS RELATED BEFORE WERE NOT
VOTING -- TO RAISE ANYONE'S
TAXES -- WE'RE SIMPLY ALLOWING
FOR LOCAL CONTROL.
AND I JUST HAVE TO RELATE -- A
PHONE CONVERSATION I HAD WITH
THE CONSTITUENT WHO SAID WHY ARE
YOU SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU'RE
SUPPORTING A 55% VOTER THRESHOLD.
AND I SAID -- BECAUSE IS RIGHT
THING TO DO AND HE SAID WHY IS
IT NOT 50% WHY YOU RAISING.
THE TAX THRESHOLD AND I HAD TO
EXPLAIN THE HISTORY OF HOW WE
GOT HERE -- BUT THE FACT THE
MATTER IS MOST MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC BELIEVE IN OUR DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY THAT WE OUGHT TO HAVE A
50% PLUS.
ONE MAJORITY ABILITY TO VOTE
THIS INSURES THAT A CLEAR
MAJORITY OF OUR COMMUNITY IS
ABLE TO SUPPORT MEASURES.
AND I WANT TO ALSO JUST TAKE A
MOMENT I DO UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT THE PERSPECTIVE OF SOME
OF THE BUSINESS TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS THAT ARE OPPOSING
THIS.
I'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
BUSINESS LEADERS WHO BELIEVE.
THAT OUR ECONOMY IS DEEPLY
THREATEN AT THIS TIME BECAUSE OF
OUR STATES LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
HOUSING AND INFRASTRUCTURE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
COMPANIES THAT ARE TRYING TO
DECIDE WHETHER.
THEY CAN HAVE WORKERS WHO CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE NEAR THEIR JOBS
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
WERE THINKING OF LEAVING OUR
STATE.
A BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE HOUSING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS HAPPY TO VOTE FOR THIS
AND HOPE THAT THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE ABLE TO AS WELL.
THANK YOU DID YOU WANT TO ADD
COMMENTS SMITH'S REVERSE ALL
RIGHT TO ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THEN --
I'LL I'LL JUST AT THAT -- I
THINK THIS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BILL -- TO ALL
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
THOSE OF OUR HOUSING CHAIR
MISTER CHIU -- AND AND JUST ADD
THAT -- IT'S A CRISIS OF WE HAVE.
TO MAKE A STATEMENT ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE GOING TO
TREAT IT AS A PRIORITY IN THIS
HOUSE -- AND IF WE WAIT AROUND --
FOR SOMETHING THAT IS A PERFECT
VEHICLE THEN NOTHING WILL EVER
HAPPEN -- THERE IT I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO SAY THAT TO NOBODY --
TAKES A RAISING FEES OR TAXES
LIGHTLY -- BUT THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN WE HAVE TO DO IT AND IF
THIS IS NOT THAT TIME -- THEN I
DON'T KNOW -- WHAT IS AND AGAIN
WERE SIMPLY ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND GETTING TO THAT
PLACE -- NOW -- MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY -- I'M SHOCKED BUT
THIS BILL ENJOYS DO PASS
RECOMMENDED SHARE.
A HOME WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES I WOULD I LIKE TO WHILE ONCE
AGAIN REITERATE THAT IN PRACTICE
LOCAL OFFICIALS PROPOSE A LOCAL
BOND OR SPECIAL TAX AND THEN THE
VOTERS OF THAT COMMUNITY DECIDE
WHETHER THEY SUPPORT.
THE IDEA OR NOT.
VOTERS WILL IT WOULD STILL NEED
TO OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORT A
MEASURE FOR IT TO BE APPROVED
WITH 55% OF THE VOTE.
ACA ONE WILL LEVEL THE PLAYING
FIELD AND CREATE PARITY BETWEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND CITIES
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SO THAT ALL GOVERNMENTS HAVE A
VIABLE FINANCING TOOL TO ADDRESS
COMMUNITY NEEDS.
MEMBERS THE QUESTION IS WHETHER
IN OUR STATES DEMOCRACY YOU
THINK ONE VOTER SHOULD COUNT
HALF AS MUCH AS ANOTHER.
I THINK THE TIME HAS COME THAT
WE SHOULD SHOW ALL COUNT.
ALL COUNT EQUALLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WE WILL AS THE SECRETARY TO CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
LACKEY NO BLOOM HI BLOOM I'D TWO
BY TWO I RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO. THREE BILLS OUT.
THE BILL IS OUT FIVE TO TWO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE HAVE AT ARMS.
LOOK AT OUR WILL TAKE ADD ONS
NOW.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE UP POWER EASILY.
IT WOULD BE KIND OF NO.
WE'RE GOING TO ADD ONS.%
YES OF COURSE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT WE NEED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIX
ONE EIGHT MARK STONE STILL.
CURRENT VOTERS TO TO TO TO TWO
I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I BILLS OUT.
BILLS OUT.
FIVE TO TWO WHAT DO ADD ONS THEM.
STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE
NINE AB TWO TWELVE BONTA.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
CHU.
CHU AYE THREE OF US THREE OF US
SIDE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SIX EIGHTEEN
MARK STONE THAT BILLS OUT AB.
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN LEVINE -- DO
PASSES A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU HI.
CHIU I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I ITEM FOR AB EIGHT
EIGHTEEN COOLEY AND QUIRK.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHIU
HI CHIU AYE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I ITEM NUMBER FIVE
AB TWELVE FIFTY THREE ROBERT
REAVIS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CHIU [inaudible]
HI [inaudible] TWO FIVE MR AND
MRS CAM THANK YOU CAME THAT'S
MEETING ADJOURNED